hey what's up everybody it is february
1st 2020 i'm dave rubin this is the
reuben report direct message live from
miami florida we are live streaming on
rumble youtube blaze tv make sure you're
subscribed to all of those places click
things adjust your monitor accordingly
and we got a major major show for you
today i think we may be setting a reuben
report record with the most elements in
a show
ever and by elements that's a little
industry talk for images and video and
sometimes audio we got a lot a lot of
stuff for you and i'm just feeling great
today because last night
i teased it yesterday but last night
jordan peterson who is back on tour back
in action and and better than ever
really better than ever i needed to see
it to believe it but i can truly say it
now uh he had me open for him at the
fillmore the jackie gleason theater here
in miami beach and it was absolutely
awesome connor why don't we throw up the
picture of me and jordan this is us
doing the the q a at the end we just it
was just we brought back the old days
the band got together it was the reunion
tour that was at the end of the show but
we put together a little
compilation of my opening i did about 10
15 minutes of stand-up just getting
everybody warmed up and and in the room
and present and excited to be there and
i was just so excited to see people
again and be in my new home city of
miami with all these great people and uh
and of course because it is miami
everyone showed up about an hour late so
the show started at 8 30 even though
it's supposed to start at 7 30 which
sort of set the theme throughout the
evening
and now
native please host of the reuben reports
dave
reuben
you know i am pretty sure i have to read
up on it but i'm pretty sure somewhere
there is a rule about showing up on time
[Music]
[Applause]
i love miami that i got here a month ago
i love everything about this place the
sunshine the beach the beautiful people
the alligators the frozen iguanas
falling from the sky
got hit by five of them today it's
better than living near gavin newsom
i'll tell you that
because the one show we did about 120
shows last time about a year and a half
20 countries the one show that was late
i swear to you was miami
you people don't care
you drive i love even the way you drive
here it's insane but i love it left
turns on your phone in the middle of the
thing yelling in spanish and someone is
incredible
how many of you were here the last show
we did in
a bunch of you miami you're here for
that so what happened you just didn't
get your [ __ ] together huh
did you even read the book
but this really this is awesome this is
what it's all about i mean really look
around this room like 3
000 people right 3 000 people all
sitting here
you know
shoulders back
trying to put truth into the world each
and every one of you who forged a
vaccine passport to be here tonight
[Applause]
jordan specifically said to me right
before i go up downstairs listen if you
see anyone with the mask
that is a true
privilege
and an honor
one more time for me to introduce
dr jordan peterson
that's just a tiny glimpse into what my
life during 2018 and a portion of 2019
was like 120 shows 20 countries and
jordan's back at it right now they're
going to do probably 80 shows they're
going to go back to europe i may join in
little spots when i can obviously i got
a lot going on my own book and book tour
coming in april
but
here and now and again when we can do it
i'm going to try to jump on jordan's got
another show in miami in a couple of
days and you could just feel it it was
electric it was exciting and actually
pretty much all of the stories the four
stories that we're going to talk about
today are loosely related to some of the
things that jordan talked about and if
you are in a town that jordan's going to
go to i can't more highly recommend any
going like he was just he's so sharp
again i said to him after the show his
movements his body movements you know he
does a lot with the hands and he does
all this stuff and the crispness it was
just all there and i hope you'll check
out the show and yeah maybe i'll do some
other surprise events so we got four
uh stories for you today first off uh
you know this joe rogan situation and
the censorship
calls and spotify putting warnings
before his shows and the amount of
formerly popular musicians now
boycotting spotify it all seems to be
ramping up and rogan is pretty much
standing still he's not letting the
machine destroy him and we will see if
he can make it all the way through so
we're going to talk a little bit about
that cbs a doctor a doctor on cbs went
after him then whoopi goldberg really
butchered something talking about the
holocaust and jews yesterday
on the view and then she went on colbert
to kind of clean it up and she may have
dug in a little bit deeper i think
somewhat accidentally so we'll show you
some clips on that then the really the
thing that i wanted to mostly talk about
because i know so many of you are
focused on it right now is what's going
on up in canada this this trucker
situation this convoy
of truckers going across the country
being supported by hundreds of thousands
if not millions probably millions of
people certainly millions of people
worldwide at this point uh is is just
absolutely extraordinary and we are
watching the government particularly
this clown this blackface clown
this modern racist ridiculous buffoon
actor justin trudeau
completely go after the people who just
want to live their lives freely as they
see fit so we got some stuff on that for
you and then finally you guys know jen
saki jensaki is the chief white house
liar she cleans up the things that biden
accidentally occasionally says that are
true
well she just went in all on fox and
misinformation and
well we'll show you some video on that
before we get to any of that people i
want to talk to you about zstack you
know in the last two years if they've
taught us anything it's that you have to
take control of your own health ain't it
the truth
it's clear that you can't simply rely on
the government or big pharma to protect
you or your family that's where z stack
comes in
is a specially formulated moon boosting
supplement supplement that includes zinc
aquariceradine
vitamin c and vitamin d formulated by dr
vlad zelenko the world-renowned doctor
that president trump credited with his
successful early treatment protocol and
his decision to take hcq zstack has been
scientifically formulated is kosher and
gmp certified and is produced right here
in the usa now more than ever you have
to take control of your health and your
family's health zstack is formulated to
help combat any and all variants as well
as the flu stay ahead of any potential
future variants by preparing your immune
system go to
zstacklife.com dave and enter promo code
dave to get a small discount off your
first order that's zstacklife.com
dave promo code dave and now back to me
all right
folks the machine
the mainstream media the corporate press
whatever you want to call it it is
coming after joe rogan why is it coming
after joe rogan is it because of
misinformation is it because joe rogan
is really a fringe right-wing extremist
is he alt-right is he a racist is he a
bigot a transphobe or is it because he
just has conversations with people and
he's curious about the world the way
most of us are or the way most of us
used to be or the most the way most of
us secretly still are but we're afraid
to show i think it's the latter
cbs this morning obviously a major
corporate press show a lot of money goes
into it i don't know if a lot of people
are watching it they did a little
segment on joe rogan and misinformation
and what should and shouldn't be allowed
on these podcasts when i had a
conversation with nils yesterday he and
i asked him and said you know some are
saying that you're trying to censor joe
rogan he's very clear he believes in the
first amendment he believes that joe
rogan and anybody else has a first
amendment right to say whatever they
want he says he doesn't want his music
his artistry associated with the
platform that would allow him does he
say other artists will follow suit he's
talking he's talking to a lot of artists
we don't have any names yet but we'll
see i mean these musicians are not going
to win this battle right you have a
first amendment right to say what you
want you don't have a first amendment
right to appear on a platform as large
as spotify that's the issue joe rogan is
correct that the medical world gets
stuff wrong but there's a process by
which the medical world corrects itself
and that process is not interviewing
guys on the fringe of the medical world
on your massive platform that's called
irresponsible it's not censorship right
editors are not sensors they're ensuring
quality the other problem too is people
say well just turn it off you don't have
to listen to it the thing is a lot of
people do listen to it and they're
getting false
incorrect information and that's why it
seems so dangerous and it matters who's
reached yeah
he just said he's having a conversation
that's what joe rogan will say it's a
life or death issue that's why it's in a
special category
he's just having a conversation that's
what joe rogan will say that's scary joe
rogan i mean there was so much nonsense
in just that little clip and you can see
why joe rogan is almost single-handedly
demolishing mainstream media and that's
what this really is all about they don't
like the competition that's really
what's going on here more people are
watching joe rogan than are watching
these people at cbs morning news and try
to imagine the amount of people that
work in that studio that prepare their
notes that tell them what to say that
are talking in their ear that do all the
lighting it's an old dinosaur in the la
brea tar pits and it's sinking and it's
gasping for its last bit of air and it
thinks that somehow if it can just latch
on to joe rogan it can pull him down
with it but that thing's going down
either way there were a couple
interesting quotes there
first off i'll go to the second part
first which was that at the end they
basically said that you know he's
talking to these fringe doctors and the
implication is that the people he's at
on they're fringe they're scary they're
out there they're conspiracy theorists
you know they're somehow weirdos
something like that uh the main
interview that this whole brouhaha is
all about is with dr robert malone who
is one of the creators of the mrn mrna
technology which is what the vaccines
are based upon he has several of the
patents he has spent at least three
decades working on this stuff there is
almost no one who is more of an expert
so they don't mean that dr robert malone
is fringe they mean that they don't like
what dr robert malone is saying in that
he has become skeptical of the vaccines
in that he has become skeptical as to
whether your children should be injected
with something just because a big
pharmaceutical company says it that's
what they mean by fringe there was also
a funny uh quote there because it was so
meaningless but it had words in it that
i had to repeat it it was just utterly
meaningless but it was a whole string of
words the doctor who was sitting there
to the left he said that you don't have
a first amendment right to appear on a
platform as large as spotify that sort
of sounds like it makes sense i mean
that is true
in that he strung words together but it
really makes no sense the first
amendment means that you can say
whatever you want and without with the
very very narrow restrictions we have on
that meaning you can't uh incite a mob
to attack somebody you can't yell fire
in a crowded theater with the intent to
do harm you can't you know uh create a
terrorist threat that sort of thing then
you can basically say what everyone the
government can't get you for it now he's
conflating this with your right to be on
a platform now of course nobody has a
right to be on a platform the platform
whether it's youtube or spotify or say
locals or rumble places that joe rogan
would be completely welcomed without
censorship uh they can decide who they
want to work with of course they can but
you don't have a first amendment right
to appear on a platform as large as
spotify well he's somehow equating
whether you have a right to do something
with with the size of the platform which
actually makes no sense and the whole
sentence actually just makes no sense
but it's one of those things you hear
and you're like oh i guess joe rogan
doesn't have a right to be on spotify no
one's saying he has a right to be on
spotify it's called a business deal it's
a open exchange of goods and services
for money the thing that capitalism
is based on
excuse me it's based on they also
implied that joe rogan is somehow
responsible for deaths that because
people watch the joe rogan show and he
has such a wide audience and they might
start thinking about things a little bit
differently than the narrative that he's
killing people
there is no evidence of this there is
literally no evidence of this now if you
were to say to these very same people
hey is there any evidence
that when you get the vaccine it could
have some side effects blood clots heart
enlargement etc etc they would freak out
they would not want to cover that are
they covering that on the cbs morning
news now we could try to cover that
responsibly and talk about it within
understanding how often it's happening
and everything else but that's the type
of stuff they don't want to cover right
when when it doesn't work for their
narrative but oh did somebody maybe get
monoclonal treatment and take ivermectin
and recover from kovid you know who did
this guy and i had leg aches for three
days and a little bit of a sore throat
drank some tea had some ricola
and worked for me uh did i just spread
misinformation did i just share
something that is going to kill people
of course not of course not and the idea
that we just can't talk about these
things
do you think that's ever how we solve
things guys guys there's just a series
of things we can't talk about anymore we
can't talk about them we've just decided
those are the things we can't talk about
the powers that be they like those
things we're not going to talk about
them does that sound like a recipe for
disaster i think it does i think it does
i think you know that it does and my
message for every one of you watching
this is keep finding the places that you
don't think are bullshitting you whether
that's here whether that's somewhere
else
i have far more faith in you than those
people do i believe you can make some
choices for yourself i believe you have
a brain
i think you got some functioning neurons
up there i think you can think this
stuff through and i think you can find
appropriate people to talk to about your
own health
but you know right wing mania that's
what they say guys let's talk about
roman healthcare you know it's almost
valentine's day and love is in the air
and whether it's a third date or a
30-year anniversary you don't want it
erectile dysfunction getting in the way
of a perfect night if you've been
experiencing ed then visit getroman.com
reuben today to speak with a u.s
licensed health care professional about
ed and if prescribed get 15 off your
first month of treatment roman offers
five prescription treatments including
the brand and generic version of the
most common ed medications a u.s
licensed health care professional will
work with you to find the best treatment
plan and if your prescription medication
is appropriate it ships to you with free
two-day shipping with roman you get free
ongoing care for ed all from the comfort
and privacy of your own home
the whole process is straightforward
convenient and discreet to make sure you
get your package in time for valentine's
day your order needs to be placed by
february 9th so don't waste any time
start a free online visit today with ed
treatments you can have the
self-assurance that comes from knowing
your you've prepared yourself for the
moment when the moment comes getting
started is simple just go to
getroman.com
reuben and complete an online visit
that's getroman.com
reuben and now back to me okay let's
talk about whoopi goldberg i thought
yesterday because we've been talking a
lot about the view when we finished the
show yesterday i thought to myself dave
maybe tomorrow we won't talk about the
crazy ladies of the view and then the
crazy ladies of the view chimed in
because the crazy ladies of the view are
doing their show on abc right at this
very minute a.m eastern so i can't watch
it live thank god and i don't recommend
that anyone does so i see these clips
afterwards
anyway they it was the holocaust
memorial day and they were talking about
the holocaust and you would think that
they would be able to talk about the
holocaust without kind of denying while
the holocaust happened but that was just
a bit too much for miss whoopi goldberg
well also if you're going to do this
then let's be truthful about it because
the holocaust isn't about race
no no it's not about racism
it's about a different race but it's
it's not about race
it's not about race
because you it's about man's inhumanity
to man that's what it's about but it's
about white supremacy
but it's not it's not about ideology
but these are two white groups of people
well how do we have to blame
him as white
missing the point people minute you turn
it into race it goes down this alley
let's talk about it for what it is it's
how people treat each other
it's a problem it doesn't matter if
you're black or white because black
white jews uh it's how everybody eats
each other so is it
if you're uncomfortable if you hear
about mouse
should you be worried should your child
say oh my god i i wonder if that's me no
that's not what they're gonna say
they're going to say i don't want to be
like that well hopefully i want to be
cool yeah
most kids most kids they they don't want
to be cool no they don't and we're
living you know we're living in an era
where people are
comparing vaccine cars to the yellow
stars where people are comparing
vaccinations to what anne franklin went
through yeah so it is necessary for kids
to learn about how they're talking about
so i learned about man's inhumanity to
man however it exposes itself i have to
cut you off i just want to say that
mouse was banned and it flew to the top
20 of amazon's rules last week
yes
all right first off i feel like i owe
you guys an apology every time we play a
clip from the view actually yesterday
you may remember we were going to show
you a clip from rachel maddow on msnbc
and we had a little hiccup with the
computer there and i saw a lot of people
in the comments going dave we want to
thank your technical people for being
unable to show that clip because i show
you these people and they're all bananas
and yet we all know we have to do it
because we have to expose the nonsense
now first off i just want to be very
very clear about something because i
know we all rush to judge everybody we
all try to destroy and cancel everybody
i do not think whoopi goldberg is an
anti-semite in any way okay i don't as a
matter of fact i think her real name is
karen walker and one of the reason
reasons that she told chose the name
whoopi goldberg goldberg obviously being
a jewish name was because she was around
a lot of jewish people when she was
growing up she lived in the inner city
and there were a lot of jews and black
people that lived in similar
neighborhoods right by each other and
she was very influenced by jewish people
i have no doubt that whoopi goldberg
does not hold hatred in her heart to
jewish people but what you see in that
clip is how confused
everyone gets because of wokism that
because she has chosen the woke ideology
as as her main
ethos in life that this is the set of
beliefs that she puts above everything
else you can see how it basically
destroys any sensible way of talking
about anything
obviously
obviously everyone knows this like this
is like basic basic stuff
the nazis considered the jews another
race they did not consider them white
right like this is basic nazi 101
so she's confused there because she has
now racialized everything so to her race
can only mean something about skin color
i will i can't believe i'm going to do
it but i'm going to give joy bajar a
little credit joy who has gone off the
deep end but at the beginning of that
clip when
uh whoopi says this about race that it
wasn't about race it was about man's
inhumanity to man joy kind of was like
well it was because they did consider
them another race so joy i know i've
been hard on you lately lady but you did
kind of pull it through there you did
make some sense there so i just want to
be clear i do not think whoopi
is an anti-semite i don't think she
hates jews i don't think she holds
hatred in her heart she's very confused
about woke-ism and says all sorts of
awful things
but now
after that and by the way it was pretty
great how they were playing the outro
music the whole time like you know the
producers were like you're with the
holocaust thing
anyway she went on stephen colbert last
night to kind of apologize and it sort
of was going well and then
i said that i i felt that the holocaust
wasn't about race
and people got very very very angry and
still are angry i mean i'm getting you
know all of the the mail from folks and
the very real anger because people feel
very differently
but i thought it was
a
salient discussion because as a black
person i think of race as being
something that i can see so i see you
and i know what race you are people were
very angry and they said no no we are a
race and i i understand i understand i i
felt differently i respect everything
everyone is saying to me and i
you know i don't want to fake apologize
you know i i was i very upset about that
people are
misunderstood what i was saying when you
talk about uh
being a racist
i was saying you can't call this racism
this was evil this wasn't this wasn't
based on the skin you couldn't tell who
was jewish they had to delve deeply to
figure it out so have you come to
understand that the nazis saw it as race
because they might like asking the nazis
they would say yes it's a racial issue
well see this is what's interesting to
me because the nazis lied
it wasn't they
they had issues with ethnicity
not with race because most of the nazis
were white people and most of the people
they were attacking were white people so
to me i'm thinking how can you how can
you say it's about race if you are
fighting each other so
it all really began because i said how
will children how will we explain to
children what happened in nazi germany
this wasn't
i said this wasn't racial
this was about white on white and
everybody said no no no it was racial
so she like sort of apologized there but
then at the same time
makes it clear that she still doesn't
understand the issues and that's what
locism does
you've diluted every sane conversation
into skin color because whoopi oddly and
i know you can't quite see it but maybe
you'll get there the ideology you've
chosen is the neo-racism so you view
skin color now as the defining thing
which is so unfortunate because you have
such an amazing career right like you're
a great actress and a great comedian and
and you as far as i knew were a pretty
moderate person
for your entire life like a great
actress ghost molly you in danger girl
like she was great won the academy award
i think she was the first was she the
first black uh woman who won supporting
actress in ghost i think she was i think
she was if i'm not mistaken um but she's
very confused so colbert actually did
ask the right question there which was
what joy was referencing do you
understand that the nazis
viewed the jews as a different race and
we don't have to whittle all of this
stuff into the difference between race
and ethnicity and everything else but
the broad point that she still can't
quite see it but i'm not here to destroy
whoopi goldberg i'm not she is she was
the first african american to have
received an academy award nomination for
both best actress and best supporting
actress maybe the other one was the
color purple i'm guessing was the other
one i know it was a ghost for one of
them uh anyway whoopi i'm not here to
cancel you you're confused and i think
if you start not looking at the world
only through a racial lens i mean just
imagine when she said the thing about
you know it was white on white you know
what i mean so it couldn't have really
been about race it's like that doesn't
really make sense or it's about it's
really about the inhumanity that humans
can have towards inhumanity it's not
about race imagine if a white person
let's just say a uh
you know a right-leaning person was on a
talk show someone on fox news let's say
this tucker carlson fella was on
fox news and he was talking about
slavery with somebody and he said you
know slavery actually wasn't really
about race it was just about
humans inhumanity towards other humans
they would be going bananas at the view
they would be saying tucker carlson was
a white supremacist he's denying racism
he's denying the history of the united
states and
but what do you mean it's just about
humans and humans are mean to other
humans that's just how it is anyway i
think you see what's going on here
whoopi
come around enough of this already it's
enough all right let's talk about the
canadian trucker story which really is
it's the story it's the story and i'm
going to keep hitting this thing and
hitting it hard
until mainstream media picks it up more
and honestly assesses it although i will
not hold my breath on that one uh first
we've got some video of the truckers and
this is just going through ottawa it's
absolutely fantastic connor let's throw
to that and i'm just going to talk
through some of this stuff
look at this i mean this is
hundreds and hundreds of trucks
thousands and thousands of people
they're saying now it could be 50 to 100
000 trucks that have made their way in
this convoy to ottawa this is incredible
these are good decent people
somebody was telling me it's something
like negative 20 out there these people
would much rather be inside it's nice
and warm inside i mean look at this it's
just absolutely extraordinary why are
you not seeing those images on cnn why
are they not leading with this story
right they'll start leading with it when
they can further twist the narrative
into that this is a white supremacist
rally right which they're really trying
to do we'll get to that in a sec but
when you just see the amount of people
out there and what are they there for
it's not because canadians suddenly
became racist it's not because canadians
suddenly decided to hate trans people
it's because canadians decided finally
to say you've pushed us far enough even
us
good-natured canadians we've had enough
eh
all right so we've got some more video
this is of the uh the convoy i think
we've got some more of that let's take a
look
uh it's just incredible so this is a
little bit further out in ottawa so we
were showing you right in the city there
and now on the way oh this is the border
actually so this is the border of u.s
and canada i mean it's just absolutely
incredible look at that look at the
amount of people and they're at the
border and they're saying we're here and
we're an integral part of the economy
we're an important piece of getting you
guys goods and services and you've
pushed us far enough and we have to show
you that we have influence and a voice
one way or another but if you want to
see how mainstream media is covering
this
here's your warning everyone loves the
disclaimers and warnings i'm gonna have
to show you these clowns over at msnbc
this is joe and mika and god if you've
ever seen more smug people i'd like to
know who they are these anti-vaxxers
actually took food from the mouths of
the homeless hungry yeah because they
were they're they're so put upon yeah
i'm just curious again where were these
protests when people were required to
take get five vaccines to start school
where were these protests when people
were required to give their children
five vaccines they were in the doctor's
office getting vaccines they were in the
doctor's office getting vaccinated they
were making fun of left wingers on the
west coast for being loopy
anti-vaxxers
now they have met the enemy and the
enemy
their enemy
is themselves because they've become
what they hated they've become what they
mocked and now they're taking food
from soup kitchens because they're so
put upon for being asked to do what
they've been asked to do required to do
their entire lives coming up
you're a
dick like what
i was i almost said it i almost said the
f word trying to control the f-bombs um
joe is obviously a multi-millionaire
that's his wife mika she's obviously a
multi-millionaire they are mocking and
she sits there like this
she sits there like this because she's
so outraged by these truckers and these
good decent people who are trying to get
control over their lives again and
risking everything that they've gotten
she sits there and they're in a cult
they're in a cult i honestly don't even
understand the point that he was trying
to make there is his point that they
should have been protesting earlier
because if that's his point then
probably yeah if all of us had been more
outspoken two years ago then maybe a lot
of this nonsense would have happened so
i don't know exactly what he's trying to
say there but the beginning
the anti-vaxxers these people are
anti-vaxxers
who are taking food from the homeless
the implication being that there's food
on the trucks or that food can't get to
homeless shelters or something to that
effect first off we have no evidence
that these people are anti-vaxxers in
the way that people would talk about
antibacterials are they anti-mandate it
sure seems like it is it possible that
75 of those people are are vaccinated
it's probable right like it's probable
it's possible i don't know all the
numbers on that nor does that idiot um
but these people they are just the worst
like they are the worst sort of elites
and i will never stand with them and i
will stand with those good people who
are out there it is just disgusting and
if you want to
see an elite guy if you want to know
what an elitist sounds like someone who
wants to rule over people who thinks
that he has dominion over the people who
have voted him into office for some
god-forsaken reason here's a tweet from
canadian prime minister justin trudeau
from yesterday
i'll try to do it in justin trudeau
voice i know this pandemic is
frustrating it's frustrating that after
two years we're not done fighting covet
19 but over the past few days canadians
have been shocked and frankly disgusted
by the behavior displayed by some of the
people protesting in our nation's
capital okay so what trudeau is trying
to do there is frame this as you know
these are terrorists they're white
supremacists the behavior the behavior
of some of these people now it's
interesting i've been watching an awful
lot of videos of these people and
they're in trucks they're waving flags
and there are words scary words like
liberty and freedom on the flags and
there's kids clapping for them and all
that stuff and i thought my god we've
got a staff of people here can we find
video of the bad behavior well we found
this
my god cleaning up trash at the end of a
protest is there anything more
disgusting
more deplorable
than that meanwhile watch what happens
at a lefty rally a climate rally when
they leave the place like it looks like
scorched earth
but then we even found more disgusting
deplorable behavior from these
protesters
oh sorry man sorry
ah
is there anything more awful than a
group of free citizens coming together
you may have heard one guy say sorry to
the other guy as he was shoveling to
shovel the public streets could these
people be more awful and most likely
nazi adjacent my god that's what the
nazis wanted to shovel streets with
other people after protests
uh this all reminds me of something that
happened last night because during the q
a that jordan and i did at the end what
happens is the audience members there's
an app and they can submit questions and
then
you know several hundred if not a
thousand or so questions come in and
then while jordan's giving his main talk
i would go through all the questions i'd
pick out some funny ones some serious
ones there was a whole slew about the
canadian situation obviously jordan is
from toronto so i wanted to talk a bit
about canada and i asked jordan
something about uh justin trudeau what
did he think about justin trudeau and he
said something that i think really
really nails it
that basically justin trudeau is the
type of personality that is almost
literally incapable of saying anything
true
he simply cannot he is so deep on the
lies he has so sold out whatever his
initial beliefs were that that is why he
comes off as so ridiculously deeply
inauthentic that is why when people go
against him he calls them the absolute
worst things that he actually is at the
point
in his
human journey that he can no longer say
anything true all he can say is
pandering drivel remember that video we
played a couple weeks back justin
trudeau talking about how much he loves
the lgbt i mean he can't remember the
letters and then
the q and the eye and the what now and
then he has some guy in the back telling
him how much he loves the community and
he just repeats it he is he is basically
like a robot who is malfunctioning at
this point he is he cannot his
programming is corrupted and he cannot
say anything true and i think if you
really put that in your head going
forward so that anything you see him
tweet anything you listen to him if you
just know that that the guy's a liar it
all starts making sense about him and by
the way
uh there are other people in canada who
are putting the pieces together so right
before we started the show i just saw
this video we had to throw it in
this is a woman by the name of candace
bergin she is a conservative member of
the house of commons and man she tore
trudeau a new one
mr speaker and i apologize that that
minister is misleading canadians i do
get very defensive of canadians who are
outside today patriotic peace-loving
canadians who are called misogynists and
racist by the prime minister
so again i will ask the prime minister
who may i remind this house war black
face on more times than he can remember
apologize to the peace loving patriotic
canadians who are outside right now just
asking to be heard will he speak to them
who would have ever thought that there
could be a better candice bergen than
this candice bergen
there she is when you say candice bergen
that's who we all think of murphy brown
that's her right there but that other
kansas burger looks just like her
actually and that's the number one
candice bergen at the moment i don't
know what actress candice bergen is
doing these days she was awesome in
boston legal as well
but that is just spectacular the man who
has appeared in blackface more times
than we can remember right like it's
just this man is so deeply inauthentic
and they have had it and they're making
canadians stand up that's that's one of
the other things that jordan said
actually about this is he said that the
situation is so nuts that when when
canada is now standing up and the world
is looking at it he's like how much more
info how much more obvious
direction do you need than something is
really rotten in the system that canada
has to stand up and maybe lead the world
out of this nonsense and they're doing
it they're doing it
here we've got video of scott mo he is
the premier of saskatchewan that's in
western canada i love that name
saskatchewan uh announcing a plan to
fully return back to normal life why
would he be doing that do you think it
may be is because the people are finally
standing up
so now
and our caucus mlas are hearing this
from the people that they are talking to
across the province and the people that
they ultimately represent
and people are asking their government
for a return to normal a removal of
public health restrictions and we most
certainly
are looking at how we can do that in the
weeks ahead here in saskatchewan and now
i think it is in fairness it is time for
us as a government to do what
saskatchewan people are asking for
that video is absolutely incredible if
you really listen to what he said he
basically is saying the people are
demanding it and now we're going to do
it because you're not going to believe
it guys in western societies in free
democracies we the people
i know we have it in our documents their
documents are pretty close not quite as
good
but we the people are in charge they
work for us and it's absolutely
incredible for this guy i don't know
much about scott mo but it's incredible
for someone as a public elected official
to basically say yeah we locked you down
we did all this stuff
but yeah you don't like it so we're
going to reverse it what does that tell
you what does that tell you it tells you
that we have the power in the first
place and it and the lesson of this
thing is that we've all got to stick a
pin in it we've got to say no more we
have to remember this moment
so that when they come again and they'll
come for climate lockdowns and they'll
come for all kinds of [ __ ] that we can't
even imagine this was the test run for
much worse stuff i think that's pretty
obvious but we must remember that
politicians can be moved they can be
moved but they can be moved by us we the
people so a truck convoy driving across
canada well suddenly you've got
politicians going oh i guess the people
are a little upset and maybe we should
do something about it
all right guys we got one more for you
you know how much i love jen saki
who is the white house press secretary
uh she doesn't like fox news very much
and she's watching them all the time to
make sure they're not doing bad stuff
because that's what the press secretary
should be doing or something like that
here's some video if you look at fox on
a daily basis i mean do you remember the
four boxes that you had that we had on
all the tvs right which is on my tv
right now so right now just to give you
a sense so cnn pentagon as many as 8 500
u.s troops on heightened alert okay true
same on msnbc cnbc is doing their own
thing about the market and then on fox
is janine pirro talking about soft on
crime consequences i mean what
what does that even mean right um so
there's an alternate universe on some
uh coverage what's scary about it is a
lot of people watch that
the smug
dismissive way that she is so
perfected
people upset that crime is running
rampant in cities
that's what those
fools are covering over on fox news
they're not covering the stuff we want
them to cover as if you are the ones who
get to decide what they show
on news networks you're not because you
don't run the whole damn place and we're
not gonna let you run the whole damn
place you get it sake i also realized
right before we threw to that clip when
i say sake sake where it comes from do
you remember true blood on hbo the
vampire show remember bill the vampire
he was always talking to sookie and he
would say sucker like that and that's
that i think that's where i'm saying
sake it comes from bill the vampire on
true blood there's some information for
you anyway i don't like this sake woman
i think news networks are allowed to
cover whatever they want but what she
really means there is oh fox is covering
our failures our meaning the democratic
party because it's the democrats that
run all of the cities that have been
soft on crime that are all crumbling and
when i did another bit on the show last
night with jordan about how many people
have moved here and it's like yeah
everyone's applauded because they're
fleeing the democrat-run
cities well sake got called out on this
very issue at the white house press
briefing yesterday
we are seeing crime surge in major
cities
and the president's poll numbers on the
topic you know there was a his he had an
approval rating on crime was at 36 and
one december poll
does that indicate to the white house at
all that americans feel democrats are
out of touch when it comes to safety or
criminal justice and you know what's the
administration's takeaway to
these numbers and the rising crime
i think we all agree or should agree
that violent crime is a serious problem
we actually saw a record jump in murders
in 2020 under the former president
and there hasn't been new fbi nationwide
data that has been released to date
there has been city some city data of
course which is important to focus on
and talk about
our view is that instead of turning this
into a political football we need to be
focused from the beginning of the
president's time
all of his time in office on reducing
crime and keeping our community safe and
that's why he's been a long time
advocate for more accountable community
policing that's why he has
supported and advocated for additional
funding for proven community programs to
reduce prime why he's working to crack
down on rogue gun dealers who sell
firearms to criminals and why he's taken
executive action to crack down on ghost
guns
so his objective is to work with
democrats republicans mayors local
leaders to work to address what we've
seen as increases in crime in some areas
but i would just note that nationwide
there has been increases in crime over
the past few years
must i even comment must i even comment
it's just meaningless nonsense that
she's saying
you all know the truth
do you live in the city
what's new york city like do you live in
san francisco or los angeles now she's
sort of addressing i'll try to give the
devil is due here she kind of
acknowledged there's some problems in
some cities
but might i remind you that chicago has
the strictest gun laws in the city and
michael we haven't done it for a while
how many people were killed in chicago
by guns this week connor do we have the
gun music we have to get that we don't
have it today we're gonna get that
chicago that old-fashioned chicago gun
music when we put the numbers up for you
chicago has the strictest gun laws in
the nation and more people are killed in
chicago every single weekend killed and
shot in chicago every single week and
you can give me yeah okay you give me
last weekend if you want so first off
797 people were slain in chicago in 2021
okay that's number one give me last
week's gun numbers i think we can get it
i'm sure we can um now the reason that
the media doesn't cover it because they
don't like who's doing the shooting and
in this case it's usually black men
shooting other black men that doesn't
fit the grand narrative so they can't
they can't show you that but the the
bigger point here is that everything
that that sake believes
is that is based around that the
government is supposed to do
uh something about all of this and that
if the government only had more power if
we had more laws if they had more money
if they could take more of your guns
that things would be better chicago is
the perfect example of why that doesn't
work and you all know it doesn't and
actually i mean i can't believe i'm
going to say this this is somewhat good
news only two people were shot dead in
chicago this weekend 22 were wounded by
bullets but they didn't die so that's
pretty good you know you'll take what
you can get chicago
all right a couple comments from our
friends over at locals and if you want
to join along we do a live stream chat
during the show every day at reuben
report.locals.com
montvern says mainstream media is always
sharing disinformation and
misinformation who is censoring them i
mean that's what this is all about right
they're realizing they're losing the
narrative they're realizing that more of
you are tuning in to shows like this
tuning into shapiro turning in tuning
into rogan whatever it might be even the
lefty equivalents of all of us you
shouldn't be watching that crap but i
guess it exists they're losing the
narrative and the more they lose the
narrative the more they have to see him
make it seem like a bunch of us are
extremists and the reason that i can see
this stuff so clearly is i have been
through this machine for the last five
years the front page of the new york
times the sunday new york times calling
me and jordan peterson and joe rogan and
ben shapiro the leaders of the alt-right
my face on the front page of the new
york times my dad was shocked when he
went to get coffee on a sunday morning
in long island did not know that david i
had no idea well well the new york times
said it it must be true uh amy says dave
have you registered to vote in florida
yet you know we just got the deed of the
house last week but i'm going to
register to florida i have to change my
license
i need i need i haven't got a haircut in
a month and a half if any of you know a
great stylist i need a stylist a hair
stylist here in south florida i need a
dentist i wouldn't mind a
yearly checkup over with the
dermatologist you know whatever i need
the stuff
but yes i'm gonna register to vote and
i'm going to fight to keep florida
florida
and finally america mom says did you and
jordan discuss the state of our
spineless politicians yeah it was mostly
about the canada stuff he talked a bit
about how he was trying to do some work
with some congressional democrats to
sort of moderate the democratic party i
think
that he's come to the conclusion that i
came to probably two years ago which is
that it was just over with the democrats
and there's room to moderate not
moderate there's room to work with the
republicans on this i think he's really
seeing that i think i think it's
something that for whatever reason i'm
in the political fight day-to-day fight
a little bit more than he is he's doing
obviously other stuff related to grand
narratives and religion and philosophy
and everything else um so i think he's
come around to my position a bit on that
uh and hopefully you know as i said at
the top of the show uh as he continues
to tour if there are one-offs that i can
jump in on uh especially here in florida
i'll be happy to do it and it was just
it was just a great night like i just
feel like a million bucks today because
it was just like it was special it was
great it was wonderful
i want to officially welcome phoenix
who's sitting right over there
to the team phoenix you know what he did
do you know what this man did who who
listened to jordan peterson podcast who
sat up straight with his shoulders back
you know what he did he was our intern
now we pay all our interns here i
believe in paying interns and i said to
him about a year ago listen drop out of
college take a job he said no no dave
i want to go to college i want to be a
college graduate
well he did it for a little while and
then he called us about a month ago and
he said dave i want to drop out of
college can i have a job
and yeah we gave him a job so today's
his first day in studio we're happy to
have him and you know what guys in honor
of that michael connor
everybody's getting guacamole today on
their chipotle okay that's the way we
roll here okay that's right guys my full
episode with marco rubio is up now on
youtube and on rumble and of course it's
ad free over at rubinreport.locals.com
and i've got a great interview that we
just taped with my buddy glenn beck
which is coming tomorrow all right got a
bunch to do
see ya sookie